foreign
on this Sunday night Canada ends air
evacuations
the new route for Canadians out of
cartoon when I'm leaving I feel like a
traitor to my country the scary reality
for Sudanese kids still left there the
battle between two premiers past and
present what to expect ahead of
Alberta's election call
the press the president and the punch
lines they couldn't say no to a free
meal
key moments from the White House
Correspondence Dinner those diamonds
through this feeling of blood of
innocent people and colonization and the
coronation criticism over the queen
consort's crown
global national
good evening and thank you for joining
us it is now too dangerous to fly
Canadians out of Sudan evacuation
flights by the government have come to
an end but there is a backup plan for
those waiting for rescue as both sides
of the conflict blame each other for
breaking a ceasefire Mackenzie gray on
the new Canadian evacuation route and
the reality for the Sudanese who are
still stuck there
gunshot sending students scattering in
the Sudanese company
a scene playing out across the city as
fighting between the military and the
rapid support forces militia continues
the Canadian Armed Forces were able to
get out two flights from Sudan last
night but they're likely the last from
the capital because of the dangerous
conditions and in concert with decisions
made by our allies no further Canadian
flights are planned from the Wadi sedna
Airfield
the dangerous conditions seen from the
sky our pilots on night vision goggle
were able to see Small Arms exchanges
um as they as they approached for
Canadians needing evacuation from
cartoon Global Affairs is providing two
options shelter in place or make a risky
30-hour journey by Road
to the port of Sudan dangerous Crown
move understanding that there are
roadblocks that there are roving bands
of rsf Fighters and if evacuees make the
treacherous Journey to the port their
departure plan isn't clear the chief of
Defense staff said Canada has both air
and Naval Assets in the area but the
city is packed with other desperate
foreign Nationals looking to get out
sometimes I just feel like when I'm
leaving I feel like a traitor to my
country I'm leaving them in all this
pain while I'm going to go and have joy
it's like sometimes you feel like a
traitor for doing that I don't know why
the staying behind could be a death
sentence for many souvenirs the United
Nation estimates that before the
fighting 50 million people needed
assistance and that number has likely
increased with water and food in short
supply before the crisis we had 610
000 children who were being treated for
severe acute malnutrition
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
has traveled to Kenya to help coordinate
the effort to get out to roughly 230
Canadians that have asked to be
evacuated from Sudan Farah
frightening situation for those who are
still there thank you Mac now while I
have you any movement on the federal
workers strike front yeah both sides are
still at the table right now trying to
hammer out a deal and as we talked about
yesterday the feds have said that their
most recent offer is their final offer
the public service and Alliance of
Canada have said that that federal
government proposal May progress on
wages and job security but no word on
working from home which is a major issue
for a number of union members now the
picket lines have been operating on
regular government office hours so
there's no protesting here on the
weekend pharah but if there isn't a deal
by tomorrow the union says that they're
going to increase their escalations by
sending in 20 busloads of picketers from
Montreal up here to Parliament Hill
because it's International workers day
and they're saying there just won't be
delays here on the hill either psac said
in an email to their members that
they're planning on expanding locations
where there could be disruptions so
we'll see how those disruptions could
change the tone of the table but far
there is one other key issue to watch
for and if there's no deal the prime
minister is headed to London on Friday
for the coronation for the King Justin
Trudeau got a lot of heat last time from
the opposition on going to New York
where there was a strike on so that
could put more pressure on the feds to
get a deal done warfara potentially
legislate them back to work
we'll be watching Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thank you Mackenzie
to Alberta now it's two major political
parties the United conservatives and the
provincial NDP are getting set to fight
for the votes of Al Burton says the
provincial election campaign kicks off
tomorrow but as controversy follows UCP
leader Danielle Smith who's facing off
against former Premier Rachel notley
lots of questions remain on who will
come out on top joining me now is Global
News Alberta legislative bureau chief
Kaiser with more on what to expect say
what is going to be the biggest issue on
the minds of Alberta voters over the
next few weeks
so far we've seen several polls now come
out and the two top issues for both NDP
and UCP supporters have been the cost of
living crisis we're in also improving
health care so we've seen promises from
both Rachel notley and Danielle Smith
addressing both of these things it's
been a big part of Smith's last seven or
eight months as Premier here and now
heading into the election she's making
more cost of living promises and the
Battleground the the city both these
parties need to win here is Calgary and
when we look at Calgary and we look at
Edmonton the two or rather the major
issue that we're seeing in both those
cities is increasing crime and violence
and drugs in the downtown core so we're
seeing again both notley and Smith
addressing both those issues and how
they would solve it if they were to be
elected
and say this also comes down to
character I mean the UCP has been in
power for four years now Smith has only
had the top job for for a few months
does either of them have an edge right
now in this race
so polls we're seeing they're pretty
neck and neck what it comes down to like
you said it's character it's going to be
defending records so uh not Lee was in
power for four years and then the UCP in
power for four years Smith and power for
about seven or eight months since
October that's when she was sworn in so
it's going to be a lot of the opposition
so the NDP bringing up what the UCP has
and hasn't done while they were in power
and vice versa the UCP bringing up what
the NDP have or haven't done when when
they were in power so it's going to be a
lot of this back and forth throughout
the election these two parties throwing
jams at each other trying to sort of
discredit the other person so it'll be a
lot of that but one one interesting note
that I found is Alberta has broken the
record now for having the most female
premiers out of any province in Canada
we're at three and no matter what
happens this election the next Premier
will also be female
now that's something to celebrate for
sure still there's a deep divide in the
province of Alberta safe days are in
Edmonton think safe
in elections Nova Scotia Will Make
History this spring when it allows
voters in a Halifax by-election to mark
their EX on a tablet it will be the
first use of an e-ballot anywhere in
Canada which ideally should help deliver
results faster and more accurately our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken reports election authorities and
political parties will be watching
closely as concerns linger around
relying on machines rather than people
to process ballots
with the tap of a tablet Nova Scotia
will be leading the way the Preston
by-election will be our first
opportunity to use e-balloting for early
voting which we are very excited about
in fact the Preston by-election will be
the first use of e-balloting in Canada
the by-election and the Nova Scotia
riding of Preston has yet to be called
but when it is later this spring
elections Nova Scotia will let a voter
mark their EX on a tablet at Advance
polls only an innovation that means an
election Night final count can be
produced in minutes rather than hours
it's an evolution of baltics there was a
time when we voted by raising a hand in
a room so there's always going to be
people that want to change and to
advance things and to make things easier
and indeed elections authorities across
the country have been cautiously
exploring inserting digital Technologies
into the voting process one big concern
I have is if it's a tight race and a
certain party loses them coming out and
questioning the results of the election
saying that you know election denialism
something that we saw big in the United
States I'd hate to see that here in
Canada so far elections Nova Scotia is
alone with its e-ballot initiative
though most elections authorities
contacted by global news said they are
watching Nova scotia's experiment
closely for now digital technology where
it is used in elections is most often
used to process paper ballots
specialized machines have been used to
scan and count votes in BC Alberta
Ontario New Brunswick again for the
first time this fall in Manitoba in
those jurisdictions as a Nova Scotia due
care is taken to ensure the systems are
hacker proof we have created an
infrastructure that sort of creates it
as an isolated system so that it isn't
visible through public means and that in
all cases a good old-fashioned paper
ballot also exists in case e-ballots or
e-counters fail the thing with the type
leading machine does seem okay as long
as we have a backup as long as there's a
paper backup that you can point to if
you need to audit result as for
elections Canada over the last decade
it's done a number of studies on vote
processing technology and right now its
conclusion is that a vote cast by a
human being and a vote counted by a
human being is still the best technology
to secure an election that said it too
will be watching the experiment from
elections Nova Scotia David Aiken Global
News
Ottawa
the noise complaint turned murder
investigation coming up the hunt for a
Texas man opened fire on his neighbors
in India at least 11 people are dead and
several more are hospitalized after a
gas leak at a factory in the northern
state of Punjab authorities evacuated
the entire area there's no word from
officials on what type of gas leaked or
what caused it
in Texas police say a suspect wanted in
a mass shooting Friday is armed and
dangerous and still on the loose what
started as a dispute between neighbors
over noise ended with five members of
the same family shot execution style
Mike Armstrong reports but first a
warning the details in this story are
disturbing
enough time has passed that the county
sheriff admits the suspect could be
anywhere the shootings took place in the
small town of Cleveland Texas but it's
only about 50 kilometers from Houston
Police believe the suspect 38-year-old
Francisco oropeza still has a weapon and
are telling the public if they see him
not to approach there's always a danger
when you've got a guy that's just shot
five people in the head execution style
according to people living in the
neighborhood the gunfire Friday night
wasn't out of the ordinary people would
often shoot into the air or at Targets
even late at night well Friday night at
about 11 30 one family asked a neighbor
to stop shooting one of the the victims
came out of the house and said hey we
have a small baby that's trying to sleep
and the man said I'll shoot out in my
front yard do what I want to in my own
residence moments later police say the
suspect likely intoxicated went next
door he entered the home and started
shooting officers had already been on
the way to the neighborhood for
harassment call they ended up finding a
massacre four adults were found dead at
the scene an eight-year-old boy was
airlifted out and declared dead at
hospital two children were found in the
home alive but under the bodies of
adults he appeared to have been
shielding them from the gunfire
man who escaped told reporters Saturday
both his wife and son had been killed we
were asking everyone for your help there
are now more than 200 officers involved
in the search there's also an eighty
thousand dollar reward now the victims
were all originally from Honduras there
were 10 people living in the house five
had just moved in earlier in the week
Mike Armstrong Global News
severe weather created terrifying scenes
in Southern Florida Saturday after a
powerful tornado struck the area
car is flipped over like toys as the
tornado clocking wind speeds at around
160 kilometers an hour ripped through
the city of Palm Beach Gardens despite
the damage there are no reports of any
injuries it comes as multiple storms
slam the State this weekend bringing
Heavy Rain hail and high winds
[Music]
I had a North American trilateral
approach to fighting the fentanyl crisis
the commitments the capabilities and the
concerns about the relationship between
the three North American countries
[Music]
it's great the cable news and networks
are here tonight
MSNBC on by NBC Universal
[Applause]
Fox News on by Dominion voting systems
the U.S President Joe Biden poking fun
at Fox news last night at the annual
White House Correspondents Dinner a
reference to the Network's
787.5 million dollar defamation
settlement to Dominion voting systems
this month the occasion is known for its
Jabs at Washington and the reporters who
cover it but Biden also took a more
serious tone attacking what he
characterized as an extreme press
lies toll for profit and Power
why is the conspiracy in Malice
repeated over and over again
designed to generate a cycle of anger
hate
and even violence
Biden told journalists at the glitzy
bash that he is working to free their
colleagues who are being held overseas
he also gave a shout out to Brittany
Greiner who was there with her wife the
professional basketball player was
recently released from Russian detention
over a drug charge
Canada the US and Mexico were embarking
on a new trilateral approach to combat
conventional overdose crisis senior U.S
officials will soon be in Ottawa to talk
about how to curb the trade but as Nita
Garcia reports the coordination comes
with its own diplomatic challenges
they've recognized fentanyl as the
foremost drug threat in North America
and now Canada the U.S and Mexico were
finding new ways to fight it together
what this trilateral you know committee
is going to be working on is you know
really look at all aspects of this
crisis and and really start to address
each one specifically in January prime
minister Justin Trudeau along with the
U.S and Mexican presidents called for
the formation of a senior level fentanyl
committee if we do eventually try to
find solutions for synthetic opioids
they will find other drugs Mike Seer
with the Canadian Association of chiefs
of police drug advisory committee says
fentanyl is being produced in Labs
across Canada at growing rates and the
trilateral committee can help identify
and address the precursors and our job
is is to disrupt them senior officials
with the Biden Administration are set to
travel to Ottawa to meet with their
Canadian counterparts in the coming
weeks to discuss strategies on cracking
down on Fentanyl and they're calling on
countries around the world to join their
Congress station the United States and
Canada committed
committed against synthetic drugs this
Coalition will launch this summer but
the crisis has left the U.S and Mexico
on the brink of what some experts say
could become a diplomatic crisis between
the two countries pushing back against
U.S criticism of his record on cracking
down on trafficking of the lethal drug
Mexico's president said more fentanyl
enters the U.S and Canada
where the rubber meets the royalty too
on all of these isn't how things
actually work on the ground getting
additional trade data and import data
and financial records can really make
some tremendous gains in the criminal
investigations the Canadian drug policy
Coalition says prohibition is the
problem there's no evidence behind why
we've chosen to regulate some drugs over
others something other than prohibition
and criminalization is what we need to
be moving towards experts agree the
trilateral security discussions focused
on the fight against fentanyl sends a
clear message about the shared threat
and shared responsibilities in
responding to itugarcha Global News
Washington
[Music]
next coronation controversy the stone
that will be absent from the queen
consort's crown and why its replacement
is opening up old moves
[Music]
the coronation of King Charles is less
than a week away and Camilla the queen
consort will be wearing Queen Mary's
Crown as she's crowned alongside her
husband this marks the first time in
recent history a queen consort will wear
an existing crown for a coronation and
with it comes controversy but not for
the upcycling for the diamonds dazzling
it
this 105 carat stone is considered one
of the most powerful symbols of Conquest
the Kohinoor Diamond's light is as
stunning as its history shrouded in
controversy some even say it's cursed
for centuries the Kohinoor was looted
and Bartered through bloody battles
spanning a series of Kingdoms it was
given to Britain as part of a treaty in
the 19th century between the Maharaja
the ruler of the Sikh Empire and and
Queen Victoria but the Maharaja was a
child there are questions about how the
conditions of this treaty were
negotiated the Kohinoor was first set in
Queen Mary's crown and later replaced
with a replica the original was moved to
the queen mother's Crown where it is now
after the death of Queen Elizabeth II
India renewed calls for the diamonds
repatriation Camilla the queen consort
has chosen to swap the contested Jewel
in her coronation crown with one from
South Africa they're using the Cullen
and diamonds I say plural because they
were cut from the largest diamond ever
found on Earth while the cullinan isn't
the same symbol of plunder the original
Stone uncut the size of a human heart
was mined on Stolen land and gifted to
King Edward VII by South Africa's
colonial government those diamonds there
were gotten through the spilling of
blood of innocent people whose only
crime was firstly that they were native
to that country some in South Africa
believe the stone is a symbol of
Britain's exploitation and its lasting
impact that led to deep racial
inequality it is very important that the
previous colonizers in the current
colonizers they need to take
responsibility otherwise they will never
be Justice instead the stone will be in
the spotlight on coronation day isn't it
a farce that it was Indian Diamond now
they have South African Diamond so what
is the difference between India and
South Africa not this Colony but that
Colony this coronation comes at a
critical time for the monarchy and those
close to the king say he understands
that and when I think of the king I
think of someone who's consistently
thinking about how do I reach out how do
I build a bridge instead of how do I
divide the tale of these two stones may
be a start an exhibition opening less
than three weeks after the coronation at
the Tower of London has the Kohinoor and
its history at the center how clear the
Stone's story will be told is the
question
and Global News will have special
coverage of the king's coronation on May
6th Donna Friesen will be live in London
at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M Pacific right
here on global
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole team here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's here
Canada is these Canada geese in
Saskatoon we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night